e
e e
good morning everybody representative
long since would you would introduce
yourself cu the to the rest of the
committee hi I'm Patrick long uh aka the
other Pat long for those of you that are
experienced at the state house uh and
represent uh Manchester award
7 right and congratulations everybody's
here except R
Pearson director jurus
yeah this is our last formal orientation
and of
the uh op office of professional license
insurance certification which we deal
with to a substantial
degree good morning I'm just going to
grab a pen so I can jot some notes down
if you have questions that I need do you
save the best for last
no we had a nice supply of Licensing
bills we could stack up to make a full
day good all right thank you so much so
just for the record my name is Deana
jurus I'm the executive director of The
Office of professional licensure very
happy to be here this morning um I did
hand out a presentation fairly high
level um really just 10 or 11 slides um
I'm sure there'll be a lot of questions
and questions that'll be um generated
just as a result of the conversation
here so I'll just um kind of start
walking through it um happy at the
pleasure of the chair um to take
questions throughout or wait till the
end whatever your preference is I think
questions during will be more focused
Perfect all right sounds
great um so I do have with me as well
this is Nicholas fry my general councel
does primary uh legislative work so
generally contact would be between the
two of us for any questions that you
have um I do also have here available
for questions um Heather Kelly is my
director of operations um deals with
many things but including um Budget
Finance fees that type of thing and then
Bethany catrell is my director of
Licensing and board admin so they're
available if there's more technical
questions um as well
so I'll just go ahead yes that person
you mentioned third last person you
mentioned is not on your sheet would you
name her and spell her absolutely
Bethany Bethany then catrell
c o t t r l l yes two T's and two L's
and what's your title the director of
the division of Licensing and board
Administration thank you just for your
own awareness I do have a third director
of enforcement I'm happy to give you her
her name and titled just for your
benefit she's not here today might as
well while you're doing yes so director
of enforcement is Sarah Rogers Sarah
with an
H D and
Rogers no d r o g
RS course yes thank you
absolutely so just go ahead and start um
the mission of the New Hampshire oplc is
to safeguard public health safety
welfare environment and the public Trust
of the citizens of the State of New
Hampshire um I I like to say if the law
says it we do it if it doesn't we don't
so uh that is my preference that's my
mode of operation at any point if we're
trying to untangle a situation whether
it's in Ru making procedure operations
we're always going back to the law to
see what does it say what do we need to
do what are we mandated to do um so
that's that's more mymo it's not very
it's not a very flashy mission statement
but but that is is largely how we're
pursuing doing our current operations so
the office structure here just to give
you a little bit of a picture sense so
we have the director the division of
enforcement against Sarah Rogers so that
is investigations and prosecutions on
that side of the house so complaints
come in they're evaluated they're either
there's a can be a recommendation for
dismissal we can talk more about that
enforcement process on a future slide
but there's investigations and
prosecutions two separate pieces of that
division licensing and board
Administration again under the direction
of Bethany Katrell that has board
Administration the office has 57 boards
that it currently provides
administrative support to seven of those
are advisory and 50 of them are what we
would just describe as a full licensing
board just for the sake of the
distinction um that division has uh
board administrators so we have a a team
that support each of them support
several boards but our assigned to them
are at every board meeting manag ing the
agenda coordinating with the chair um
technology different pieces basically
that service to the boards um licensing
which is individ and customer service
are in that as well so that is the folks
answering our phones um and then issuing
credentials responding to emails I have
a few more details on a future slide
about that as well and the third piece
over there is compliance
so um that is inspections now in the PLC
400s so
cosmetology facilities are inspected
pharmacies um and then other pieces so
where there's a compliance component
it's not necessarily enforcement it's
just ensuring that they're complying
with the the statutory and the
regulatory mandates so those are all
live in that division that is our
largest
division um the third is operations so
that is Heather Kelly that includes
Human Resources Finance Information
Technology contracts project management
and anything else that I
need on currently and Under the Umbrella
kind of of the executive director's
office is general counsel and board
counsel so those are so that would be
attorney fry and then I also have an
attorney Elizabeth Baker who provide
agency counsel and then there are three
positions that are um designated as
board councel they're assigned
specifically to boards they're in every
board meeting advising the boards
providing them legal support during
their meeting
and then the hearings Bureau also
reporting up to the executive director
we have two administrative law judges
this um before the reclassification from
dop would have been um a hearings
officer basically a presiding officer um
for adjudicative and Licensing
proceedings um and then one hearings
clerk that facilitates the
administration of that I will pause
there it's a big a big umbrella overview
but if you have any other questions I
will get into more details but how many
uh hearings off officers
two and then one clerk so just the three
down
there so what's the total uh number of
Staff in your in the um oplc now I'm
going to look at Heather it as you
understand that it's fluctuating
regularly just with hirings and
departures and changing over there do we
have a head so authorized is 120 I think
currently filled positions is closer to
104 accurate
yeah the next slide I will uh not bore
you with reading every single border
profession that we thank you very much
that we regulate but just for your own
situational awareness and if you're
wondering does that live it OPC or
somewhere else this will provide you an
exhaustive list of what is here I will
just make a quick note um out of Al
alphabetical order at the very end I
just I have douas lactation consultants
and Community Health worker those are
new voluntary certifications that we're
currently engaged in rule making on um
we're engaged in that process right
now would you mind indicating the ones
that are
advisory
yes was going through the list assessing
certification is advisory
I'm going in alphabetical start from the
top certification
yes yes there's seven there are seven
yep body art
practitioners court
reporters
electrology scrolling down apologize
massage
therapists medic Medical Imaging and
radiation
technology Imaging and radio yep about a
third down the second column there we're
up to
six medical technicians medical
technicians is not presently an Advisory
Board recreational
therapy seven all right actually Medical
technicians aren't exactly a board
they're just a profession right there is
currently no there's not presently a
board that is correct thank you yes and
then um around that same thing opthamol
dispensing professionals is also just a
credential there is no Associated board
with that
profession
okay moving on to the next
this is pulled directly from the statute
but I figured just for a a broad picture
I would go over the Executive Director
responsibilities for RSA
3104 so responsible for supervision of
division directors um currently has
Chief legal officer and Chief of Staff
those positions the legislature was um
included in a bill last session those
positions have not been posted or filled
uh due to uh current budgetary
constraints so those those are vac
um pending
funding um you said chief of staff and
which Chief legal officer thank
you so again employment of personnel
needed to carry out functions of the
office and the
boards examination processing and
approval of denial of an application for
lure certification or registration for
all license
types so the the Nuance there is the
boards the licensing boards they will
determine the objective standards for
the lure so the professionals that are
assigned to these boards are developing
the criteria and the office is the one
that's basically doing the processing
and the evaluation if there is a
question about whether a leny has met
the qualifications whether it's
something very technical or related to
the profession then staff are sending
those to the board for review for their
expertise so if there is a question
we're not guessing we we're Consulting
the
board um letter D is the investigation
of all complaints of professional
misconduct so again the office is
responsible for that investigation those
reports of Investigation go to the board
and then adjudication or a dismissal
that action is taken by the board from
there maintenance of the official record
of the office and Boards in accordance
with the retention policy so that's just
the all the the record holders are not
held by the boards it's held just by the
office um so any compliance with um 91a
records requests are processed by The
General Counsel office not by individual
boards um letter F Drafting and
coordinating rul making for all boards
within the office with advice and
recommendations of the boards so in that
case that is the same across every board
whether advisory or a licensing board is
that we're getting advice and
recommendations now if it's a the full
licensing board they have their own
chapter so um optometrist is one that I
was reviewing yesterday so that's
Optometry rules and they have their set
if it's an Advisory Board it would be
part of the PLC so the office chapter
related to that profession but again in
consultation with those advisory boards
who are the technical experts in that
regard and then yeah so letter G I
already alluded to maintaining
confidentiality of information documents
and files in accordance with 91a
the the last one in that statute I left
off because it just says I have to
produce an annual report and I didn't
think that was particularly relevant for
this discussion but it is in
there wanted you quickly so those are
the executive director kind of the
office responsibilities and I wanted to
go over the board
responsibilities I touched a little bit
on board versus Advisory board so the
rule making is the first piece
here um just to give you a general
outline of how are laid out the 100s
would be organizational rules
definitions um kind of just general
grounds um table setting if you will a
criteria for initial lure would be
established in the
300s criteria for Renewal would be in
the 400s as well as continuing ed
requirements ethical standards would be
in the 500s generally and then there's
other regulation scope of practice you
know Pharmacy goes up up to 2600 they
have pretty extensive rules so anything
after 500 is miscellaneous at the
determination of the board and the
office in the drafting there but if
you're if you're looking for
organizational rules initial or renewal
you're looking at one three and 400s for
any given profession or the PLC rules
which would control the process for
those things so just to give you a
little bit of a
framework the disciplinary process again
for boards they make the final
determination on whether to investigate
a complaint or dismiss
it that
determination can happen at two at two
points so the office under goes an in a
facial review of a
complaint if they determ that it is not
determine that it's not legally
viable there will be a dismissal memo
drafted and sent to the board and say we
recommend that you dismiss this
complaint the board does not have to
dismiss it they could say nah you really
got to look at this again send it back
up for investigation so that's the first
the facial review we say dismiss it the
board says go take a closer look send
comes back up to enforcement that
determination could also be made if the
office says we think there might be
something here Pro produces a report of
Investigation at the end of that make a
recommendation to move forward they
could say either dismiss or move forward
so then the board would make a decision
there so those are kind of two parallel
tracks pending that facial review yes um
thank you I
I've had some some uh concerns from
lenses that at that point you should be
reporting back to the
complainant that the board accepts or
rejects the uh complaint is that your
common practice that is that is the
common practice I I have been hearing of
instances where that has not occurred so
we're tightening up that process in
policies to ensure that is happening
because that is the goal is to notify
them when a matter is closed they know
it is over yes yeah or even thank you
for your complaint we've decided it
merits investigation and we'll be
working on it m i mean either way the
the problem is when someone makes a
complaint and it you know
radioes yes I I will add we did
Institute a reply um just when a
complaint is um when it is filed just
even just confirming receipt of the
complaint and saying thank thank you for
you know for filing this here are the
two either it will go this way out you
know that it'll have this review it will
either go to the board so basically kind
of laying out what I just laid out for
you here are the next steps you will
hear from us in these instances so I'm
hoping that provides some clarity that
isn't a new within the last month new
kind of just communication out to
complainants thank you that solves one
concern
yeah I will keep going pending
questions
um so they um they make the final
determination on whether to dismiss
issue a confidential letter of concern
or commence with a disciplinary
proceeding so similar piece there they
are the fact finders in disciplinary
proceedings so if we are in an
adjudicative hearing the board sits as
the finders of fact they work uh
frequently with board counsel to produce
those findings of
fact um for the presiding officer uh to
impose sanctions in disciplinary
proceedings
approve or deny settlement agreements in
disciplinary
proceedings they decide motions to
dismiss that are based on fact in law
with the presiding
officer they can emergently suspend a
lenses license with the presiding
officer and they can delegate any of
their disciplinary proceeding
responsibilities to the presiding
officer so um one instance there's a an
Emergency process which I'm happy to
talk through probably I would have
attorney fry talk through it he has a a
really good understanding of that
because distill for you um but one
example would be 3:00 on a Friday
afternoon we receive a complaint that we
would consider emergent that action
needs to be taken expeditiously we don't
want this person to be able to work to
practice through the weekend because of
whatever alleged violation uh those are
quite minimal it's it's not a regular
occurrence but they do happen um to
convene a board in the last hour or even
you know we could work late but on a
Friday afternoon would be quite
challenging so we do now have the
opportunity where if something comes
down to hearings and we need that we can
work with the board chair we can try to
get a quorum if we cannot get a quorum
available for that they can delicate
that decision to the presiding officer
to be able to move forward um in that
case so that's what is covered in that
last bullet
point I've never heard the adverb ently
does that mean on an emergency basis or
in case of an emergency yes is that what
that wow that's quite a word thank
you we always try to make Edna
educational I will all right I'll keep
going the next slide for licensing as I
mentioned already the board is
responsible for determining the criteria
for lure under statutory scheme as
permitted by law
um consult with the executive director
on criteria for licensure by endorsement
reciprocity under 310 so that is the um
there's a lot of different words that
are used somewhat interchangeably but
the the license your reciprocity that's
the portability if you're licensed in
another state that piece there the word
endorsement is used for clarity I think
I'm not an attorney but I think when you
say reciprocal it implies it goes both
ways we obviously can't tell other
states what they have to do so it is by
definition we cannot say it has to go
both ways we'll accept you and you
accept us um that's more of a compact
model but again that's a different
mechanism so licensing by endorsement is
the
implementation of um HP 594 from 2023
that would say that portability between
states making recommendations to the
office on how to proceed with processing
and application so again that was if
there is a question uh criminal
background check comes back and we need
um some consultation there there's
pieces um included in that and then act
as a FactFinder in licensing hearings
upon request of the office
recommendation of the board request of
the applicant or upon board decision so
there's a there's a lot of variables
there if you get too technical I'll kick
it over to attorney fry
but again would you mind walking us
through the process my daughter
graduates as a nurse okay what she does
her Clinic
who examines her who says uh she's
qualified do you send the papers who
keeps track of her hours uh how does
that actually happen can you mind
walking
through Mary scitech nurse um if you
don't mind i' I'd love to have Bethany
catrell come up and answer that just at
some point if that's appropriate now or
when she's going to get to
it I think that was be appropriate now
okay
okay good morning Bethany Katrell
division director of Licensing and board
Administration nice to see you all um so
every uh license type is a little bit
different in their processes but nursing
for example if um I graduate from my
nursing program say I go to St a I
finished my clinical hours all of that
has been documented through the school
and then once I graduate I apply to oplc
um to take my exam what we call it is a
ATT they apply to take their test um as
a new nursing grad I then get approval
from oplc to sit for that exam and we
let the exam company know um and that go
ahead the the bo oplc administers the
exam or the we uh nope we have a third
party that administers the exam that we
have on contract with okay sorry we're
lucky that we're all very collaborative
so we're very thankful to be able to
work together um during that time the ly
has like a provisional um license where
they're able to work under certain
restrictions which you wish correct and
then uh we get the results back from
their exam they have to have their also
their FBI criminal background check done
and then once we get get all of that
together then they get their full
unrestricted license which you would you
deliver that you send the paper we uh
email them but yes they receive that
from us you get an email certificate
yes wow it's not nearly as dramatic as
it used to be right it saves a lot of
money in postage so we're much more
fiscally responsible when you have
thousands and thousands of
lenses I do um want make a comment about
that so last year
one of the things that we did was we
gave the office the authority to issue
the licenses and an online system was
put together so that what was typically
happening and correct me if I'm wrong
was that somebody would send an
application in by mail it would be
missing a document so the office would
have to mail it back to the person with
all their packet have this thing added
mailed back and it was this going back
and forth that was causing an issue and
so now the way the system is is imple it
implements itself is that someone
applies through the portal and unless
they've attached all those documents
properly they can't go to the next step
so there isn't this regurgitation of
male going back and forth and I think
this has from what I understand and from
speaking for the people who have who um
have requested licenses the process
is uh is flows better yeah and I will
say um excitedly that yesterday we run
our numbers uh bi-weekly and so
yesterday I was looking at our bi-weekly
reports for new applications and
statutorily we have 90 days to make a
decision on our applications um that in
the past because of this back and forth
that representative grto was talking
about um often has gone beyond that uh
yesterday when I looked 87% of our
applications were were a decision was
made within uh the 90day time frame and
57% were within 14 days so Within 14
days 57% of our applications were
approved and out the door which is huge
especially compared to other states why
shouldn't it be 10 minutes not 90 days
once the third party sends back that
they passed the test and submitted their
credentials so in the nursing situation
the initial application is that first
part where they say okay I've graduated
and can I take the test and so then we
have to approve them they have to take
the approve them to test they have to
take the test so there's there's pieces
in there that that do delay that um
Engineers for example have up to two
years to take their exam so that could
delay the initial application to when it
actually gets approved some of those are
the outliers um but we are within uh two
weeks most of our applications are being
approved and out the door why does
anyone need approval to take the test
that's
not yes representative
long why does anyone need approval to
take take a test uh if that's not the
final step in their licensing process
because you could always deny the
license on some other basis if there's
some other reason they're not
eligible it's an interesting policy
question I it really it changes not even
just board by board profession by
profession so some have statutory
requirements that they have to be
approved to sit for the test some boards
have made that decision in rule that
they that they would have to approve
members to take the test we could get I
don't have off the top of my head the
number of boards that have that
requirement but there are there are more
than one that would say you they they
control who can sit for the exam before
even considering the
application you don't you don't make
that you don't make the decision who can
sit for the board the boards do right
the board set those rules or the statute
uh and then we Pro or deny based on that
correct
yep yes if you want to do some statutory
cleanup on this issue I'm sure it be
well rep this goes back to my point if
the law says it we do it if it doesn't
we don't if you change the law and says
you cannot approve anyone anyone can
take the test that's what we will do
yeah
okay thank you thanks
Bethany so then then just the last piece
here kind of our miscellaneous catchall
is um issuing declaratory rulings on its
rules or on the statutory scheme so
sometimes a question comes
up somebody petitions the board and says
what what do I do in this scenario what
would happen the board can issue a
declaratory ruling to give Clarity on
that piece of it and then standing
orders related to its statutory
Authority so a board can issue a
standing order to say every single time
this happens I want X to happen please
don't ask me and have an hour convers
ation every time it
happens yes saying a criminal record
check that only has one Wii doesn't need
to be considered by the board for
example yes and we do um specific to
criminal record checks we are working on
we have it established for several
boards we'd like to have it across all
boards that require that criminal
history check that there is some
standardization where it says where the
board agrees here are the instances
where we don't need to see it just issue
the credential 100% of the time we're
going to say yes you don't have to bring
it to us or here's the ones that we
still need to see so we're working on
implementing that across all of them
we're partway there on that piece of it
I believe that came up representative
McGuire we were talking with the lak
board specifically there were some
challenges there so I think that that
has quieted down and we'd like to do
that across across everything um just
touching on a few more licensing and
customer service numbers so in 2024 we
had 212 12 plus that number is always
fluctuating active
lenes um our population has grown so my
20% of the state is not quite accurate
because we're up over 1.4 million dollar
um not dollars people now in population
but a large percentage of the state has
a credential from the office to work um
and that's constantly it's constantly on
my mind a a conversation I'm having
regularly with staff is that we need to
continue to be efficient effective not
do more than we need to do
um And Timely resolution of these
concerns because this is people's
livelihood it's it's their ability to
work and so that that is top of mind for
me at all times um
profession so if I
take let's just take I take 2500 people
which is in the begin in the middle of
20 of 2,000 and
3000 and If I multiply how how long I
guess I'm saying that if we take let's
just say we take 50 weeks okay that's um
50 I don't I don't let me just do it the
top of my I can't do it off the top of
my head so 5050 time 2500 is
125,000 people so how can we
have and and a license is two years
right so does
that so we're saying that we're turning
we're turning it over every two years
and that requires 2,000 to 3,000 people
a week so that's that's a really rough
estimate some weeks it's under a th000
some weeks it's 8,000 uh if it's
renewals so there it is extremely
variable these expiration dates are the
it's from the date of issuance so this
just to give you a general sense of the
amount of licenses that they're
processing somewhere 2 to 3,000
sometimes it's a lot higher sometimes
it's a lot lower but this is just to
give a General a general gauge of of how
many they're processing week in and week
out follow up follow up because one of
the um things that we did change was
that rather than every two years on an
anniversary date which was causing this
big clog of Licensing was that we would
do it would be doing it would be done on
the date of
issuance so do you think that I'm sure
that change over is still in process
that's what I'm wondering I think that
change over is probably still in process
and and there are some I will say so
nursing is a good example of this all
nurses graduate from school at the same
time they all sit for their test at the
same time right or at two or three times
in the year so you have very busy
renewal periods just based on the school
calendar so it's not that they're
required to be issued on a certain date
by anything except for most of them are
taking their exams in May so there's a
large there there are still those large
Seasons there just for the situational
Awareness on them one less thank you so
maybe perhaps what it might what might
be interesting to us is the number of
lenses you we have 212 lenses so maybe
we pick you know
what do will the 8020 rule apply do 80%
of our lenses fall under a certain
number of specific boards you don't have
to answer that question now but it would
be interesting to know M the uh the
annual
report um we've I've only seen the 20
through
report oh I apologize I do think I sent
it to you I will I will send it to the
committee please yes we'd like to see
that has a report of how many licenses
per board yeah so I we I know so not for
the purpose of this presentation but I I
know exactly the number of lenses for
every single board and and as director
katell mentioned I we I could send you a
report of every two weeks the exact
number of credentials we issue I don't
think you want that but we do have those
numbers we do want the uh the annual
liing yep happy to do that repres Howard
oh representative Schmid thank you madam
chair so I I I appreciate the the value
of
standardization uh in in many
instances what works for board X can
work equally well for board y board y uh
but are we do do we know that a standard
license uh period is is appropriate
for all boards all professions and so
forth are we are we looking at what
other states do to see whether uh we are
evolving as as the board uh as oplc
evolves I mean uh some of us were here
before the oplc was I'm one of them uh
and and it's gone through a lot of uh
twists and turns with executive
directors who were relatively shortterm
and candidly uh not all that effective
um so uh it sounds to me like like oplc
has get gotten kind of through the
Shakedown uh period of uh
of discovering that this doesn't work
that well and no let's do it this way
and give it a try or whatever so I think
we're at a point that where
we're into a more intermediate stage of
development uh but are we let's get into
my individual question so are we looking
at what other states do with regard to
duration of
licenses um I have not personally looked
into that I will say well you've only
been in the position for relatively
short period of time you're you're in
your Shakedown period to some degree as
well getting to know what what you're
doing and how EXC me representative
Schmidt the duration of the license in
all cases is specified in statute we are
the ones who should be looking into what
other states are doing should we wish to
make a change well I I I it take the
chair's a correction uh for the value
that it has uh but the thing
is some of us are brand new some of us
are quite old and have been in this
position for a long time so to the
degree that we don't have the kind of
global experience that that a board or
an organization such as oplc would have
because they attend conferences they
interact with all kinds of other states
in many respects so I think it's what
they what they learn
from working with other boards in other
states is something that they should
refer to us for statutory changes I
totally get that but that's that's the
direction I'm going with my question I
haven't noticed any hesitancy on the
part of the boards to request statutory
changes when they want them so I mean
they I think three or four boards have
have come to me this year for statutory
changes that's interesting I'm glad to
hear that but the point is we have
whole half of our committee is brand new
to the legislative process as well as to
this this committee so so I'm exploring
things which I think the new members can
benefit from discussing or hearing
raised by more experienced members of
the committee and so forth but also from
the director uh so if you don't mind I
I'd like to have an answer to my
question I would just add so again if
the lot says it we do it if it doesn't
we don't uh the two-year license period
is extremely helpful to us operationally
because we're on a banial budget and so
it makes Revenue much easier to predict
we're much more accurate in those
predictions what because we know every
two years this is ex not exactly right
we don't know how many people will get a
license but it's much easier to predict
within that two-year window so for the
process of budgeting Revenue estimates
um it
is again we if you said nope three years
we would make it work but it
operationally we really do actually like
the two years what other states are
doing uh their their funding sources
might obviously um be significantly
different than ours as well so for the
current process that we have now where
it's you know uh all agency funds it's
set by fee it's very helpful to us so I
just anecdotally say that we we would
certainly not request that you change
that thank
you anyone else all right thank you okay
um
I I'm really excited to um just
highlight our customer service team so
between licensing and customer service
we have about 35 Staff members um that
their their full-time job is answering
the phone answering email issuing
license credentials they do an excellent
job um we're answering between 95 and
99% of calls presented and 100% of daily
emails um Monday was a abnormally high
but on Monday the office in the seven
and a half hours that well the eight
hours were open fielded 350
calls uh it is it is in the thousands
every week it it is quite extensive um
so we have a large team that is doing
that um and uh director Kell highlighted
this piece of the um the licenses so
more than 80% we're issued within 30
days and that's I put the dates in
specifically because between 1228 and
110 would be holidays lots of people on
vacation we have a lot of renewals so
even over this holiday period more than
80% of them were out within a month so
I'm just um I'm really excited about
that um kind of going back to a little
bit about what representative Schmidt
was talking about the office has
undergone a lot of changes um and with
that so with Law changes comes rule
changes comes policy changes um we're
still building a lot of those processes
out the focus certainly was we need to
get licenses out the door and we need to
answer the phone and so that side of the
house the Licensing Division um has
gotten a lot of work a lot of procedural
pieces there
um and you can you can see by the
Numbers we have the the data from this
time last year to now as a dramatic
Improvement and and I'm really happy to
be able to share with you um that leads
me to my next slide to say that the
enforcement side of the house is next
and that's the plan for 2025 is to
really iron out those processes uh to
ensure that our data is good that
there's a timely review of complaints
that the investigations are thorough but
they're expeditious and so to give you a
little bit of a sense here um the
division is currently auditing all
pending complaints to verify the status
so there were a number of factors here
um there was there were some data issues
like physical in the the system that
need to be verified there's fields that
are incorrect and so now we're looking
into every single indiv individual
complaint to to ensure that that data is
accurate um and to verify this is indeed
a complaint all of this is accurate the
other piece that they're working on is
the review for legal viability so that
the facial review I talked about at the
beginning where a complaint comes in and
it's initially reviewed was not
completed for complaints that dated back
that were in the backlog when that law
went into effect and so what we're
trying to do is go back and do that
review as well to say do do we have some
more that we can recommend dismissal for
here and then chip away at the backlog
so um they're currently working I have
messages in my phone right now from the
division director who says that we're
we're even further Expediting that
process the goal is to be done within
the next three weeks of all to verify
all of the complaints to have that data
be clean and then to start working
through that
backlog um so you can see the numbers
here we have 271 verified and say almost
exactly 10% of the
2771 unverified pending complaints so
that's a large number um I am
undeterred we're uh we need to make sure
that the data is good I don't want to
send investigators out on something I
need to ensure that it is a verified
complaint before we start doing that
work um we're working to streamline
processes collaborate with boards I
think um with all of the changes that
happened with the office one of the
things I think is there there sometimes
was a perceived division between the
work of the boards and the work of the
office and I just don't see it that way
um in conversations I'm having with the
board I say look we all have the same
legislature passing our laws right we we
we have the same statute and we have the
same boss we all work in the executive
branch especially even for myself and
board members we all have the same
appointing authority we all work for the
same people we're doing the same thing
and so I'm trying to if there was a Gap
close it and even if it's perceived
close that perceived Gap to say we're
all moving in the same direction we all
want to ensure public health and safety
we want this to move as efficient as
efficiently as possible and we want to
we want to protect the public um and so
that looks like this improved
communication with them collabor ating
seeing okay we're sending you dismissal
memos and you're just not agreeing and
you're sending everything back up what
do we need to change and they're saying
we need more details you can't just say
dismiss it we know right we give us some
more specifics tell you know um just a
few more words on a page so a memo
instead of a half or three qus of a page
it's a little over a page the board can
able they but they have enough
information that they feel like they can
make an educated decision and that
they're they're um they're not afraid
they're missing something so that's one
that we're instituting we're we're
collaborating in that way now we can't
always talk specifics of a case because
they have to sit as FactFinder in
adjudication but just to speak generally
what what can we do how can we work
together to move this forward and uh and
I'm excited about the progress I I do
think we're we're moving in the right
direction um I monthly call a monthly
call with all the board chairs I'm
hoping to increase that attendance I
don't um you know we have 57 boards I I
might have 10 at any time that would be
a higher week and so I I'd like to
facilitate more of that conversation I
do think the ones who attend find it
profitable and so just trying to make
sure that we're open and we're moving
forward in that way I'm happy to talk a
little bit more enforcement and my
director is not here and like I said
that this is the one right I I want to
be able to come and give you the
licensing slide but for enforcement at
this time next year
so lay um thank you madam chair um thank
you for being here we spent some time
together last year here with um a with a
bill that dealt with the medical the
Board of Medicine and review um pretty
much what you're speaking about right
now we walked away from that interim
study bill saying that you guys were
going to work together in order to find
a process um I was curious if that's one
of the ones that's moving along smoother
or because there were some big issues
that led to that discussion is that
something that's still a work in
progress I would say that all of our
enforcement is a is a work in progress
um but I I think the the collaboration
between the boards so that the potential
wedge that I was saying that perceived
wedge I I do think is removing I'm I'm
in their board every month when they're
there um we're we're in communication I
think we're we're getting ourselves on
the same page to all move in the same
direction so there there is not
animosity I do um so I think it's
there's no quantifiable way for me to
say that except for that the the
relationship is much better the
collaboration is better and I we are all
moving forward in a good direction so I
I'm I'm optimistic about specifically
that board thank you that's helpful
yeah
um uh I wanted to touch a little bit on
rule making I know that this is the
policy committing it's it uh it is not
the joint committee on legislative
uh I won't even name the acronym you
know what Jil car is um oplc was
responsible for over 25% of the initial
proposals in the rle making register in
2024 I like to highlight that because um
I I'm very supportive of all my
executive branch Partners but I I have
one full-time and two part-time people
doing rules in this office and we do 25%
of the state's Ru making so I'm I'm very
proud of that we we do need some
additional resources there's a lot of Ru
making to do but we are getting it done
um with the limited staff so I have I
have three not even three full-time
people doing 25% of the state's rules
just because each board has its own
Practice Act there's a lot of rule
changes that are happening regularly so
I like to highlight the work that
they're doing um and if any of you are
on jail car get ready you'll be hanging
out with us a lot you expect 25% in 2025
also Pro
probably yeah because uh see bullet
point to um we're still working with
boards to update rules in light of HB
655 and then 1095 that statutory cleanup
um there's um yes so I think there's
still going to be quite a bit of rle
making um I wanted to just touch on so
RSA 31016 includes a new mandate for we
making specific to military service
members so right now we're working with
individual boards um we have contacts at
the department of military Affairs and
veteran services and so we are um we're
working on that that is going to involve
a lot more rule making that's a pretty
comprehensive project I have one staff
member who is the lead on that who was
coordin ating organizing um scheduling
time with boards specifically to discuss
this outside of any other rule making
that they're doing or other business um
there is some winning of hearts and
Minds because it is a little bit of a
shift it's not traditional education um
but we're very committed to it and um
excited to see progress on that in this
year so you will see I think across
several boards you will see rule making
specific to that piece of it
questions thank you um the last piece
here is um I'll just touch really
lightly on budget and fees again I know
this is a policy committee and that is
why I have director Kelly here if you
have specific in theed questions you
don't want me to answer them therapist
by training so um we're now responsible
for fee setting for all Associated
professions um so we have a fee package
that we're working on the proposal it's
going to accompany our next banial
budget uh we are awaiting Direction on
what that budget will be and then the
fees will be set accordingly to the the
cost there and this will this be in the
governor's
budget the our budget will be in the
governor's budget the fees are just set
in rule it's the PLC 102s and that will
be a jail car proposal but we're we're
not putting the cart before the horse to
say hey give us our fee Revenue before
they've set our budgets well you know
the the the idea is is that the uh
budget is set according to the
fees at least that's what the state does
so yes so we we also yes all right thank
they will be in tandem that is certainly
true
yep any general
questions specific questions
anyone representa so I'm concerned about
the enforcement frankly because um that
is the piece that I think is difficult
to
tackle and um so I'm just wondering
if when you said that you would have a a
better idea in a
year I'm sorry not a better idea what my
hope is to have the met the success
metrics that I'm able to present to you
for licensing and customer service these
are good percentages the time like we're
efficient we're getting things out on
time what I'm saying is that took some
time right it was a year of ironing out
processes making progress forward so my
my hope is within a year to have that
success
story we're always improving but that
success story so not that in a year I'm
going to know what's happening but in a
year I can say here's the number of
cases that we got through here's the
work that we're doing here's the H the
time in which we're processing cases and
that it's going to be a much better
story than I have presently well so how
would we know that happened in a
year I'm I'm assuming I will be talking
to you again at at some point or uh
happy to have a special meeting I mean
I'll probably see you every week for the
next six months right yes okay that's
great so in a year we'll and and it
would be reflected in my annual report
which I will send to you now in my 2025
annual report hopefully would have that
as well representative Schmid thank you
madam chair so we have a new governor uh
one of the issues that we have heard on
this Committee in the past was that that
I have heard in any case uh from uh
people who have experienced it uh that
some boards have um members who are well
beyond their uh cell by date so to speak
and they're above beyond their statutory
limit in terms of how long they've been
on the board U and I've heard complaints
about people who uh need need to be
replaced um and we not replaced by the
previous governor so we that's why note
the fact that we have a new governor but
she's going to need to know um from you
about uh complaints or uh a situation
where people are on the board for too
long and where they the their term has
been exceeded and they're still there
because they haven't been replaced when
they should be so is that something
you're that you're specifically aware of
and looking into and so
forth I think this committee will recall
I I'm personally very vested in that um
as it was my responsibility in the
previous governor's office for several
years to be looking at those vacancies
across the entire State um so we're very
aware of that I I don't know what this
um what governor aot's preference is
going to be for um receiving that
information but we we have uh all in one
place the roster of all board members we
know at any time um any vacancies any
members who are in hold over we're
regularly communicating with board
members as well to see if they are
eligible for reappointment and
interested that they're personally
keeping them like themselves in in the
mix shall we say um so we are keeping
tabs on that and um and at any point can
and and do communicate that there are
these vacancies and uh again as a person
who looked at boards and commissions
full-time for a long time um keenly
aware of that uh I think it is a tale
that is not unique to any state many
Governors um get doing lots of things
and boards and commissions are not the
most exciting piece of U of any
executive branch so but I will keep it
at the Forefront because it does it
impact we have about 350 volunteers that
come through every month in this office
so there's there's no other agency
that's looking at that right the board
members there's a lot of board members
so um we're definitely aware of that and
and like to keep that up to date as you
know our process says it goes through
GNC uh and and uh and it is it is a a
real drudge to try to keep on top of
that situation because it there are so
many people involved um and uh and so
finding people uh but we also I served
on another committee 20 years ago before
coming to this committee and we had a
situation where the where the committee
chair went to the then governor
uh not Governor sonunu a long time ago
um and said we don't
want such and such a commissioner to be
reappointed the our committee the
previous committee it was was uh not
satisfied with that commission and and
our chair went to the governor and said
do not re reappoint this person so uh
that that's a pretty drastic step for a
committee to take but but we do hear
things because we're the eyes and ears
of our citizens but also of the
executive branch in many respects um and
so
uh we will want to know that uh that you
are receptive to input from our side as
well always happy to hear from any of
you thank you and there are four of us
on the committee you you
indicated if any of us are there are
four of us own the jail car the three
ladies we talk with them regular myself
the last session we had
a a notice in the house calendar saying
we're looking for public members of Bo
of the boards did that provide enough
success that we should repeat
it I didn't hear of any who applied
because they saw it it doesn't mean that
they didn't but that was not stated as a
reason that they were interested so I
don't we'll wait a while then I can't
say it not to but I don't I don't know
how much it yielded yeah I think we'll
wait a while and then it'll be new again
when we put it in I do appreciate your
support in that yeah all right does
anyone else have
questions
comments excellent job then thank Youk
you got the comments uh for the
committee we will be resuming at 1 pm we
have four public hearings on licensing
bills
so take a break go for a walk whatever
if you're interested in the budget the
LBA is presenting to uh Finance
today
e
e e
all right for the uh committee's
reference I uh wasn't up on the
current uh rules and did not announce
that we would have executive session
after today so we will not exec any of
these bills um if we agree on any of
them that need it we'll do those next
week on licensing
day and it being 1:00 I'm opening the
hearing on House Bill 271 and I call the
sponsor representative
Schmidt thank you very much Madam speak
Madam
chair no attempted Monument here um but
I am pleased to be before uh this
committee
today Peter I can't see a beautiful face
I don't know who who he's trying to fool
but uh it's it's a nice compliment um so
I'm pleased to be before you on behalf
of Hospital 271 FN and if you open the
um the bill
you'll be uh urged to uh don't blink
your eyes or you'll miss it uh because
it's a very simple bill but but it's an
attempt to address a real situation and
it's a serious bill um most of us I'm
sure are very well aware of the fact
that we have all kinds of Labor
shortages across the country not just in
New Hampshire but we are not being
spared from the scourge of uh of
shortage uh in a number of important um
professions and occupations and uh
social workers are among th those in
greatest need um and this is a build to
attempt to address that Ma matter and we
have uh several people to testify uh and
answer any questions you may have so
I'll take no questions but please pay
attention to the witnesses that we've
arranged for today and give them your
your thorough attention thank you thank
you Lyn Stanley
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee for hearing my testimony today
thank you representative Schmidt for
bringing this bill forward uh and please
for the record my name is Lyn cier
Stanley I am a social worker and I am
the executive director of the National
Association of Social Workers New
Hampshire chapter pleased to be here in
support of this bill I'd like i' like to
give a little bit of history and context
just so you know where this lure tier
came from and also uh in the mix of
alphabet soup what this is and what this
is not so about four years ago Senator
Bradley and new Futures were looking at
the challenge that we were and are
facing around people who are in
emergency departments awaiting
psychiatric hospitalization looking at
what some of the barriers to Services
were what they found one of the things
that they found was that the adults who
were awaiting psychiatric
hospitalization the majority of them are
on
Medicaid when looking at the children
who are awaiting psychiatric
hospitalization the majority of them are
on their parents' private insurance and
this is important because our community
mental health centers have a Medicaid
waiver which means that the services
provided by anyone regardless of lure
whether they have their masters or their
doctorate every service gets covered by
Medicaid however for private
insurance which the majority of these
children are
on private insurance requires that for a
service to be reimbursed that the person
who is providing the service hold a
license so the
solution three and a half years ago was
to create two additional licensure
tiers one of them was the licensed
social worker that's a bachelor somebody
who has graduated from an
accredited Bachelor's in social work
program we are not talking about that
license the other license was the
licensed Social Work associate
lswa this is somebody who has their
associates degree or their bachelor's
degree in something other than Social
Work might be Human Services might be
psychology could be a number of
things in providing the
in having these two additional lure
tiers that would allow for agencies to
bill for these Services provided by
people who do not have a master's or a
doctoral
degree the
uh what we are looking to have one of
the requirements for the licensed Social
Work associate in statute right now is
that they sit for the bachelor's social
work
exam that is uh put forward by aswb
which is the Association of Social Work
boards we are looking to have that
removed as we believe it is a barrier to
people being able to actually access
this licensure
tier the reasons why we are asking for
the exam requirement to be removed is
that we believe it's it's not necessary
the these these people a lot of them are
case managers Family Support Specialists
are already providing these
services without a
license it is also expensive and we
don't want for one more we don't need
for one more uh Financial barrier to
stand in the way of somebody um getting
their lswa their licensed Social Work
Associates um
not only to take the ex exam test
preparation if they don't pass the exam
retaking the
exam I will say
this bill does not remove the exam
requirement for any other license your
tier it is just for the licensed Social
Work
associate thank you for hearing my
testimony and I'm very happy to answer
any questions that you might have
thank you um I do have a question sure
uh these people have been doing the work
without a
license in Community Mental Health
Centers and other agencies case manage
because there there wasn't a license
there was not a a license available
isn't it against the law to to do mental
health practice without a license it is
against the law to do Psychotherapy the
licensed Social Work associate has a a
narrow scope of practice there are
things that they cannot do that the
licensed independent clinical social
worker or other Master's level or
doctoral level can do these include
Psychotherapy differential
diagnosis and signing off on uh
treatment
plans those things are can only be done
by somebody who has their license
independent clinical social work uh
marriage and family therapy license okay
thank you that so this we're talking
about case managers Family Support
Specialists people who support the work
oftentimes in in people's homes or in
the community thank you representative
groa and then representative sellers
thank you um so I just want to make sure
that I understand up until three and a
half years ago when this
requirement was put in
place it was a way for people who had
who were um LS
swas to be licensed so that the agency
could build for their work correct right
so what you're saying is that you want
them to continue to have this license
and no test
correct so how do
we what's the point of the license then
the point of the license is so that the
agency can Bill third-party Insurance it
is also a step on the professional
development ladder follow up follow but
there's no requirement I mean you're
saying that they can get a license but
the requirement is that they have a
bachelor's in something oh no there I I
apologize there are other requirements
that they have have they need to have a
supervision agreement in place they need
two years of
supervision be before they can get their
license if they have their bachelor's
three years of supervision if they have
their
Associates
um and yes they they have there are
other requirements beyond the exam we're
just looking to have the exam removed as
one of the requirements because we think
it's it's a real barrier followup follow
up so this test this is is it a national
test yes it is
uh aswb the Association of Social Work
boards has the test for bachelor's
General and clinical and Master's social
workers thank you representative Sellers
and then de
thank you thank you madam chair uh my
question is
um these uh workers at this point
without the requirement for the license
do you see them working at the our
school systems and our school districts
as part of the Seal program that they
have in places now social emotional
learning with the thank you for the
question I'm
not I have not heard of anybody looking
to get their social work associate
license to do that work because it would
be about
billing private insurance and usually
schools do not Bill private insurance as
far as I
know I I guess I'm I'm unsure whether or
not somebody
would would do that I'd H I'd have to
think more about whether or not that is
is a possibility for them okay
representative re thank you madam chair
this may not be a fair question so uh
please feel free to say so but is the
impediment the cost of the test or is is
the impediment the passage rate of the
test it's both uh
the the cost is it's $230 to sit for the
exam if you do not pass it it's another
$230 and people's spend
hundreds hundreds on test preparation
materials books flashcards
classes uh the pass rate
for the bachelor's level exam is
70% first time and that is for people
who have their bachelor's in social
work that's not people who don't have
their degree in social work
work Madam chair would you um the how
about the what would be the passage rate
the first time around for people who do
not have their bachelor's in social work
do you happen to know that because those
are the people who we're talking about
here right right if the passage rate say
for example were 30% I'm making up a
number competent I do I do not know what
the pass rate for people who do not have
their bachelor's in social work would be
my assumption is it would be
considerably lower okay thank you so
much yes thank you repres Leo um thank
you madam chair and thank you for taking
the question uh so is the role of this
position basically clerical and setting
them up with Services when somebody else
is making the care decisions or are they
actually using some of those skills that
are on this
test thank you for that question uh
it is possible that
there I will say it is likely that there
are things on the exam that would be
pieces of knowledge that the person
who's doing this work should
have
uh and skills that they are
using one of the but I think that is
covered in the supervision
and
also uh one of the other requirements is
a
30-hour um prescribed training that
covers all the social work competencies
in between the time that they have their
supervision agreement on file with oplc
and getting fully licensed so not only
are they going through this this 30-hour
training over the course of two or three
years but they're also getting the
on-site training and supervision at the
Community Mental Health Center or other
organization that they're working
for follow um and thank you and with
that supervised training is that just a
receptive training or do they need to
test and show their competency in it as
a part of that training program they do
not need there is no test um with that
30-hour training I think the showing and
meeting competencies is happening within
their workplace where they are where
they are already doing the work and uh
and discussed with supervisors and um
colleagues okay more follow yeah um
thank you um then this is my last
followup you said that normally it would
be more of the administrative clerical
but they would sometimes from well yeah
that from time to time they would need
those skills how confident are you that
in that training when they're supervised
and in the train TR course they'll have
enough exposure to those more critical
parts that are covered in the test um
just by because you know that you know
the number of hours you spend in a chair
doesn't always correlate or following
behind somebody doesn't always correlate
to the depth of what you've
learned thank you for the question and I
I think I
would I'm not sure that a standardized
test
is always the best measure of what
somebody's competency and ability is um
what it might mean is that you're good
at taking standardized tests um
I I trust in the
supervision process and uh and the
experience that that these case managers
and family support workers and and other
non-masters and doctoral level workers
are are bringing
uh and I also want to emphasize that I
am a strong believer in consumer
protections I am
a i fiercely want to protect uh anybody
who who uh any client any patient who
comes in in contact with with social
workers it's a top priority if I thought
that there was any chance that this put
the public in danger I would not be
sitting here we would not have asked for
this bill to be brought forward thank
you other questions pres
long so if I understood you right uh
Medicaid was able to pay to get this
work done uh even without a lure process
uh so what do they do or what do other
states that don't have this do to to
ensure quality standards are met in this
same type of
work thank you for the question I the
the reason why Medicaid will cover these
services for the Community Mental Health
Centers is because the Community Mental
Health Centers have a Medicaid waiver
other organizations and agencies do not
have a Medicaid waiver um they're either
absorbing the cost or the cost is being
uh passed along to the client or the
client's
patience uh when you look at other
states that do have similar lure tiers
for people who have their Associates or
their
Bachelors
uh I think we have a more rigorous
process in that requirement of the 30
hour
of of prescribed
training um but those other states like
Massachusetts like Maine are able to
bill for the they are able to build
private insurance and Medicaid for those
services does that answer your question
followup sort of but I guess I would
assume that when Medicaid issues a
waiver there's still some process they
go through there or some demand they
make uh to ensure that a quality service
is still being provided so what were
their standards or what are their
standards for providing the waiver for
equivalent work to be done that's beyond
my knowledge um I know that the uh the
people who providing this direct service
are
supervised things are sign somebody else
has to take a look at what's going on
and sign off on it okay BR Zone sellers
thank you madam chair just to make sure
I heard that clear so this person would
always be working under a licensed
person correct
okay yet they cannot work
independently
okay representative Pearson thank you
madam
chair early on you you mentioned um
something that occurred in the senate in
a duration how long is how long has this
Proctor exam been required in New
Hampshire thank you for the question
I'm you don't have to give me like exact
dat is this something that's been less
than five years more than five years 25
years what what are we looking at here
um I took the I took the exam back
in 2006
so and
for longer than that so for so for the
for the Masters and the clinical
level uh the aswb exam has been around
for decades decades and this is the exam
you want to do away with the exam I want
to do away with is the bachelor's level
exam for the license Social Work
associate that's the only licenser
that's what I'm talking about how long
has that exist how long has that a
requirement New Hampshire to to since uh
the bill came forward three and a half
years ago and the lswa was created
that's what I'm looking for three years
this has existed okay but but the test
itself has been EX in existence longer
for decades it's just that we are
expanding the number of people we're
requiring to take it correct and I will
say even though the bill passed three
and a half years ago people have only
been able to get their LS their licensed
Social Work associate for six months
there was a whole Ru making
process to date we have
one lswa in New
Hampshire uh that appears to be very
small number yep it is okay thank you
that's interesting any other questions
representative re thank you if this were
to pass um how does this speed up or
enhance access to me what is the impact
how does it enhance access to mental
health care for children who are
awaiting care does it speed it up by a
day a week what is the outcome thank you
for the question I don't believe it
speeds up the process for people being
able to get Services one bit what it
does potentially speed up is the ability
for the agencies and organizations to
get re re ured for their
services we we are not changing the
number of people who are doing the work
we're changing the amount of work then
get reimbursed you yes thank you others
represent
broa thank you
so did
the we put this in so that people could
get reimbursed but the
but it was at that time the
reimbursement was tied into taking the
exam at the time
the ability to get the license was it it
is in statute that they sit for the exam
right so they can hand the licensure if
they sit for the exam and that was the
bill that was introduced three and a
half years ago yes and I believe the
rules were just finalized is that
correct correct okay thank you thank you
other
questions thank you very much much for
your testimony thank you Andrew Hosmer
thank you very much Madam chair uh my
name is Andrew Hosmer I'm a senior
policy adviser at pretty strategies my
client today is the Association of
Social Work boards who you've heard
mentioned um earlier uh today um I will
only take a couple minutes of your time
uh but I I do want to hit on some
highlights here I appreciate the
opportunity to testify uh in front of
Edna uh but I will let you you know the
Association of Social Work boards is
strongly opposed to House Bill 271 FN
the aswb licensing exams play a
critical uh and crucial role in
advancing safe competent and ethical
practices to strengthen the public
protection and to solidify social net
social work as a
profession this legislation which seeks
to eliminate the licensing examination
requirement for licensed social worker
Associates threatens to undermine mind
both Public Safety Professional
accountability and the overall Integrity
of the social work
profession a couple of is little
something for to clarify who a aswb is
aswb is a nonprofit regulatory
organization formed over 40 years ago to
assist States in fulfilling their public
protection mandates aswb is the
nonprofit organization composed of
Social Work regulatory boards and and
colleges for all 50 states the District
of Colombia and uh some other uh
countries besides the United States aswb
is the only nonprofit organization
dedicated to Social Work regulation
their mission is to provide support and
services to the Social Work regulatory
Community to advance safe competent
ethical practices to strengthen public
protection
um this bill pertains to RSA 330 capital
a colon 18 small C which became law in
2021 and uh as we have learned this this
afternoon rule making was promulgated
and completed just 6 months ago
certainly this was a broad a bold step
on behalf of the legislature and the
governor to respond to uh what was going
on uh in the behavioral health the
social uh excuse me the behavioral
health and the mental health Realms
after 2020 and 2021 it was to increase
capacity to address the concerns that
that uh many people really needed this
care and there didn't seem to be enough
uh Workforce to respond to it in 2024 as
well um the interstate social work
licensure compact became law with a
promise it would help build capacity as
well if I'm not mistaken it came out of
this committee last year and was signed
into law in July of
2024 on behalf of the aswb we really
believe it's too early to determine the
impact of RSA 330a 18c and the comp and
the compact uh and making a significant
change to lure at this point is really
premature I will share with you there is
Broad support for licensing exams within
the social work profession a
groundbreaking survey conducted by the
Association of Social Work boards
reveals an overwhelming endorsement for
preserving Social Work licensing exams
some of the numbers 78% agree that new
social social workers should pass the
exam for lure 78% 73% believe removing
the exam would be a
mistake 76% see the exam as essential to
upholding the Professional Standards of
social work we certainly believe that
licens share is a public safety
imperative license share is a
Cornerstone of public protection and
Social Work ensuring that practitioners
meet rigorous standards of education
training and competence
we also believe that lure enhances
professional Integrity it upholds
professionalism it facilitates
Interstate Mobility so more people can
be served and it certainly does support
reimbursement one of the most important
things to aswb certainly is considering
the unintended consequences this bill
may have though it may seem like a
simple fix to a problem a barrier to uh
this um designation we think the
unintended consequences though are
really grave we really don't know
exactly what they are it's a change it's
a significant change in policy to
facilitate a reimbursement correction
and we think that's a little too bold at
this time particularly given that the
the new law 330 really hasn't been en
forced for very long at
all consequences of HB 271 would extend
uh to clients who rely on licensed
social workers for essential Services I
would ask you to remember and I'm sure
that you already know and I know this is
shared by a social workers Association
these are some of the most fragile
people at risk people that our social
workers are dealing with right now we
certainly believe that this exam really
has to do with practice it's not
necessarily clerical as uh and I
appreciate the question representative
Lon this is really will impact the
clinical skills exhibited by our social
workers so I'm happy to take any
questions uh and wrap up my testimony
right now thank you very much for your
time thank you are there questions
representative
lung so if this is work that is getting
done in other context such as a Medicaid
waver or potentially just not getting
reimbursed uh even when there is no
licensing what Public Safety problems is
it creating there uh and how does
changing the exam requirement for
licensing prevent those
problems thank you for your question
representative I don't know if it's
necessarily I can speak to the problems
it's creating right now what I will say
is a standardized exam testing the
competency of people who are dealing
with our most
vulnerable um uh friends and family
members and constituents is certainly
levels the playing field I would liken
it to in in some respects whether you're
practicing law your certified public
accountant or your commercial airline
pilot the academic portion of all of
that is critically important but
ultimately those who pass the test then
possess the license to do this really uh
high-risk work and I would suggest um
social workers it's a high-risk work as
well and we think that this is really a
standardization of the licensing and
plays a critical role in vetting as we
see it's not an easy exam 70% pass rate
I'd say that's consistent with the bar
exam in many states as well and it's
certainly those that I'm familiar with
who have passed not pass those uh lure
examinations go back they have to dig in
a little more and when they do pass I do
believe they emerge as as better
Professionals in their chosen
field thank you did I answer all your
questions there representative or did I
miss
something um well I think you answered
it the best you're able to give the
information aaable
appreciate representative Leia uh thank
you madam chair thank you for being here
and thank you for that information about
the role uh my question is um since you
seem to have a more of a national
perspective as well how many other
states have this category of the
licensed social worker associate and uh
I'm just curious about the utility
overall I understand why people would
want it but I'm trying to understand how
it fits into the whole red whole
framework thank you for the question
representative lean I do not have that
information uh uh right now um but
certainly when this law was initially
passed the the idea was to build
capacity and to create another category
and um I I think we see this across the
country that we are trying to build
capacity in all 50 states to make sure
that those in need of care receive the
care but in growing those numbers we
strongly believe that anything that
lowers the standard of Entry May
compromise the ultimate benefit we hope
that patience and fragile individuals
receive thank you question be um before
I leave to Madam chair I have
um a letter from the
um Chief Executive Officer of uh The
Association of Social Work boards I'd
like to leave with you and I also have a
letter um that I'd like to leave with
you from uh Sheila Reno finigan who is a
licensed clinical social work from
Pembrook and they're both in opposition
to the bill as well you care which side
I hand it out
to representative Pearson is the closest
okay thank you uh I'm the mailman but I
also have a question yes representative
Pearson thank you madam
chair and I'll have to lead with this
are you familiar with the interstate
compact that's been
referenced I though I I am Vaguely
Familiar with it yes so I've got limited
knowledge of it my question may be for
you as well because my concern is that
if the is that a lot of the compacts
that we enter into have standards have
minimum standards have basic
requirements because you are in entering
into a compact where you can function
across state
lines uh my concern is the relevancy of
this exam to the interstate compact and
if there is a an effect with the compact
if we remove
this it um
my understanding is that this is a to
find that out Mr do you think you can
check that for us thank you thank you
madam chair thank you for the question
I'm happy to defer we do we do need to
know that before
deciding all right any other questions
thank you very much thank you madam
chair thank you
members all right Jake Barry
good afternoon Madam chair honorable
members of the committee my name is Jake
Barry I work for new Futures as Miss
Stanley indicated earlier uh we worked
very closely uh with with you the
legislature and with uh the nasw back in
2021 when lure was originally
established I don't want to repeat too
much of what has been said this
afternoon I do want to emphasize our
strong support for this bill uh and I do
want to uh sort of reinforce a few
points that have been made uh when the
legislature initially passed uh Cate
established lure it was not done so to
enhance quality services or patient
protections as Miss Stanley indicated it
was done uh it was done to bring uh more
financial resources and greater
Financial stability to our our mental
health uh uh our mental health system um
certainly to this day uh we
have l lwa who continue to practice at
Community Mental Health Centers without
passing the exam uh or without being
licensed and they do their jobs very
well uh
and you know certainly again as Miss
Stanley said you know we are an
organization that strongly strongly
believes in service quality we would not
support anything that we believe that
we're going to uh uh lessen the quality
of of mental health treatment uh
available to patients but we do think
this is an important step to uh undo
what we think is becoming what could be
become is becoming an unnecessary
barrier to lure uh and therefore an
unnecessary barrier for uh uh the influx
of insurance reimbursement dollars into
a system that desperately needs this
money to be able to uh hire more
professionals and provide more uh
services to those in need um so I think
that is it I'm happy to take questions
though I'm sure others in the room can
answer them better than I can um
actually you might know more about this
is this a step on the progress to Li
insur as a mental health independent
mental health counselor or is this a a
low-level position that the people in
that position would stay in that
position you know it certainly depends
on the professional You Know It uh uh
you know the these are important
services that are provided primarily
Case Management Services helping
individuals to access the treat you know
the treatment they need as far as you
know but many of the uh Professionals in
this may seek further lure to become you
know treatment providers themselves uh
so you know we do hope that this does
help to create and sort of reinforce the
career ladder that it does ultimately
lead to further um you know
professionals up the chain as well but
but these are critical services that are
being provided at this level as well do
I understand you correctly that it is
not part of the normal progression of
lure I again the you know the law was
just passed in 2021 we just got through
rules through last year so it's hard to
tell I think yeah okay other questions
representative Leon uh thank you madam
shair thank you very much Mr Barry for
being here um you probably know I'm new
to this committee um could you could you
tell me which Committee in the house
this bill came to and how it was
received with this language oh my um if
you don't know that's all right we can
look into it but it' just be good to
know sort of what the feel of the
committee was when it came through the
house yeah I I can tell you you know I
think in the end it passed with with
strong bipartisan support but as far as
which committee I don't recall which
committee it went through I
apologize thank you we'll have to find
out represent
Gro thank you so
here's a little bit so I looked up 330a
colon 18c sure and it's about and it's
entitled The licensed Social Work
associate initial license yes and it has
some requirements and
typically when one has been un you know
has worked under a supervision
capacity after that
supervisory period is over then the
person that has the license would
there's an
understanding that the person would
graduate from that position to The
Next
Step C certainly that's an option that's
open for sure yes mean that's what's
typically I think about licensing I
don't think that everyone's going to
stay in the guppy pool forever and swim
around there they're going to eventually
but what this is what you're
asking is for us to eliminate that test
and allow all the people who wish to
stay at that initial licensing to stay
there yes that's right that's right and
certainly and and um you know again
understanding that there is a level of
supervision that they are coming in
having been educated and trained you
know I think that uh um as you said this
is initial licensing uh uh um you know
and we just it's important to bring
people into the field in this way it's
important to support the work and we
don't want to see unnecessary barriers
uh that again don't exist within the
community mental health system by the
way thank you other
questions represent sitech uh Mr Barry
so if someone God forbid wants to
advance they would eventually have to
pass exams
written C so that does not go away no no
absolutely not okay other questions
thank you very much Mr Barry thank you
this bill will be going to
subcommittee
much much more than it looked like at
the first pass uh House Bill
267 representative Kelly
it has the new one hasn't arrived I keep
forgetting to bring one of the old
ones good morning Madame chair and
members of the committee um I am Diane
Kelly representing Hillsboro District 32
um and I am here today to int introduce
HB 267 which regards um
oh um which regards Chiropractic for
animals um those of you here last term
may remember the previous iteration of
this bill which was expertly shephered
through a subcommittee by former
representative Tony leus and a whole
bunch of really dedicated um members who
were um able to work with the various
stakeholders um such as the two New
Hampshire chiro practic associations the
New Hampshire veterinary board and oplc
to craft language that allowed licensed
chiropractors and veterinarians who
attended a nationally recognized animal
Chiropractic program which was to be
determined by the executive director of
oplc um to adjust animals without
requiring uh veterinary referral and for
chiropractors um working without direct
supervision of a veterinarian for those
of you who were not here last year I'll
give a brief beef brief background of
why this is important um in the United
States chiropractors are considered
primary care doctors which means you
don't need a referral to see one so you
can take your child to a chiropractor
without a doctor referral but currently
with animals it's kind of a gray area
and one that is currently being
addressed by a lot of States um and will
eventually have to be addressed by all
states um because um people are becoming
more and more aware of the benefits of
Chiropractic for animals um at this
point um getting veterinary referral can
take weeks because there's somewhat of a
shortage of veterinarians and um it can
also be prohibitively expensive so
[Music]
um in my own um my own uh interest in
animal chiropract came about as a result
of someone plowing into my truck at a
gas station um I had my little dog with
me he was in a body harness buckled into
a dog car seat but um he was seriously
injured and he was miserable and
probably wouldn't have survived without
benefit of an amazing chiropractor who
in one visit fixed the problem relieved
his pain he did this big old doggy shake
and wagged his tail and off he went he
was fine um last year we also heard
testimony from a woman whose dog wasn't
doing well and she and her husband were
not in a financial position to take her
for veterinary care but they heard about
animal Chiropractic and also within just
one visit the dog was back to her happy
self so uh anyway the the bill last year
sailed through the house and the Senate
and um at the last minute there was
concern about the lack of explicit
language uh regarding who is eligible
the original Bill language said that
anyone attending a nationally recognized
animal Chiropractic program would be
exempt from Veterinary license licensing
but um since only chiropractors and
veterinarians can get in those programs
no one really expressed concern at that
time but at the last minute it was felt
that the language should be more
explicit it and more explicitly Express
that only doctors of Chiropractic and
doctors of veterinary medicine who
attend a nationally recognized
Chiropractic program would be exempt
from Veterinary licensing so with this
new more explicit language it's my hope
that New Hampshire can move forward with
this matter settled so that caring
animal owners can access this amazing
care quickly and
affordably thank you are there any
questions from the committee
representative
Schmidt thank you madam
chair representative good to see you
again uh
so is this bill is essentially or is it
only is it identical or is it only
essentially similar to the legislation
you brought to us in the last year that
did pass uh the house as I recall um and
did die in the Senate what happened it
was V by the governor Ved by the
governor the there is a report from our
researcher on the history of animal
chiropractor bills which we have
provided to you thank you so is it is it
the same bill it's it's essentially the
same the only thing that changed is that
the former Bill said anyone attending a
nationally recognized program and it now
says any veterinarian or chiropractor
licensed chiropractor who attends these
nationally recognized programs follow up
yes thank so as I recall there there
were a number of people that came before
us the last time with similar stories of
difficulties in getting an appointment
with a chiropractor to have a referral
to with sorry I Had It reversed getting
a referral from a veterinarian to be
able to to go to a
chiropractor uh and to the degree you've
got an animal in pain discomfort
dysfunction um and you're waiting
for weeks whatever with an animal can't
tell you it's so it's back a little bit
farther right and I'm really hurting and
I really need help yeah um so that's the
only change and um I spoke with one of
the um directors of the Chiropractic
Association last night who said that he
both he and the other Association were
fully on board with it now so I think we
going to hear from them I don't see them
here but um I I'm happy to to um get
written testimony from them or something
if you'd like
uh anyway as far as I know everyone is
on board with the new language it just
the reason we didn't worry about it last
time is because even though it said
anyone who attends a nationally
recognized program would fall under this
um we weren't worried because you had to
be a chiropractor or a vet to get into
the program but somebody just wanted it
to be more explicit so this passed on
consent here and unanimously in the
Senate consent in the house and
unanimously in the Senate so I think
that with these slight changes nobody
will object and it should should go
through nicely represent
Howard thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question uh so I'm
looking at the governor's veto message
and the talking about uh and talking
about his uh reason why he said that
there was a number of concerns brought
up by stakeholders have those been
addressed yeah I'm not quite sure why he
said a number this was the main problem
it was um uh as far as far as I have
heard it was a president of one of the
Chiropractic associations who's no
longer there but um it that's the thing
they wanted addressed all right thank
you thank you representative
long I got an email from a veterinarian
opposing this who said I forget the
exact details but said something about
there not being any exam or any sort of
performance
standards uh that people will be held
accountable to uh and I'm just wondering
do you know what's involv involved in
completion of an animal Chiropractic
program and if that involves some kind
of performance examination to ensure
people actually have the skills of the
program is right thank you for asking
because apparently there was a
misunderstanding last year about that
very subject that there it was believed
somehow that this was going to eliminate
licensing and it does not the people who
go are either veterinarians are already
licensed chiropractors and I don't know
the details of these programs but they
are nationally recognized programs with
and it it specifies that it has to be
programs accepted by the director of
oplc and they are currently practicing
all over the country and several states
have already addressed this and are
moving ahead
brilliantly so it's not just anyone who
wants to practice you have to go to a
nationally recognized program and you
would already be a chiropractor or
veterinarian anyway so you would
understand the mechanisms and and
training anyway
other
questions thank you very much and
representative if you put in a pink card
our clerk would appreciate it will Doo
thank you is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on House Bill 267
good afternoon I'm Kurt aronberg I'm the
New Hampshire state director for the
Humane Society of the United States and
uh we would like to put in a word in
support for the animals and the owners
that want to utilize a
chiropractor we believe this bill allows
him to do that without any other
problems at this point
thank you are there any
questions thank you for
youry all right representative Howard
sorry uh yeah I just wanted to say uh
for online uh sign-ins we have foreign
support one in opposition all right and
on the previous Bill uh it was six and
six for those who are interested so
that's much more
controversial anyone else wishes to
testify
not seeing any I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill 267 and we have a
couple of minutes before the next
one
e
e e
thank you it is 2 o'clock so I will help
open the hearing on House Bill 85 and
introduce the prime sponsor Carol
Maguire thank you madam chair members of
the committee I'm Carol Maguire from
representing marac District 27 which is
the towns of Allenstown dunar
Epsom and hooks it and House Bill 85 was
a request of the hospital
Association what it does is it creates a
temporary license for student
respiratory therapists to be employed by
hospitals doing the portions of
their profession that they have already
learned under the supervision of a full
lure it's a temporary license because
it's only while they are comp completing
their
education and if you want more details
there's a member of the hospital
Association ready to speak on it I will
answer any other
questions seeing none thank
you um Kathy bazaro therber would you
like to present thank you
good afternoon Madame chairman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Kathy bizar thumberg I'm the
Executive Vice President NE Hampshire
Hospital Association representing all 26
of our state's Community Hospitals as
well as our specialty hospitals the
hospital Association supports House Bill
85 and we really appreciate
representative McGuire's Prime
sponsorship of this bill the orig
origins of this bill stem directly from
Health Force New Hampshire a Statewide
collaborative of healthcare
professionals including Educators and
respiratory therapists who work with our
Hospital
and they help to grow retain and sustain
a skilled Healthcare Workforce in our
state they reached out to us to share
that many other States including Maine
Vermont and Massachusetts allow
respiratory therapy students to work
under a temporary license they have seen
firsthand that students opt to work in
other states not New Hampshire because
they can easily obtain a temporary
license to work while still a student
respiratory therapists are really hard
to recruit as of October 2024 based on a
recent report that we uh Co collated
there was a
21.7% vacancy rate for Hospital employed
respiratory therapists if we could
encourage students to work while going
to school here in New Hampshire there
may be a higher higher likelihood of
them deciding to stay and work in our
state once they have graduated we need
to remove barriers to recruiting healthc
Care Professionals such as respiratory
therapists and this bill is a great step
in that direction so the bill does
essentially three things it adds a new
SE ction for a student temporary license
and defines the limited scope to being a
student working in a healthcare setting
under supervision who may practice for a
limited period of time and may only
practice the skills that they have shown
competency in this also requires rul
making by
oplc it adds language to distinguish
routine a student practicing their
clinical skills strictly as a student
versus working as a temporary
temporarily licensed respiratory
therapist and lastly it requires that
the student must show their employer
their temporary license so thank you for
the opportunity to provide our comments
on this bill and happy to answer any
questions representative scitec you
repeat your second point please the
second point was it adds language to
distinguish between a student practicing
their clinical skill set strictly as a
student so many uh clinical students
usually spend time in hospitals
practicing their skill set while they're
a student versus there's also time that
they could spend working and getting
paid for that work to uh work under a
respiratory therapist during their time
and that would be when they would be
temporarily
licensed follow up so this would
authorize them to work in addition to
their student activ practicing their
skill set correct the second question if
I may yes uh would you spell your last
name the thunberg part sure it's uh t h
u n b RG and you should have re received
a copy of my testimony as
well thank you thank
you are there other
questions representative you so this
might be better addressed by oplc but in
the case because I see that in Ru making
they'll be the ones who um put together
the rules for this if a student decides
that they don't want to be in this class
anymore and they leave the school I
would imagine then they would lose their
license to they would lose their
temporary license right because they
have to be enrolled in the class I
believe that would be the case and I'm
sure oplc could address exactly how that
would uh be structured they'd also would
lose their supervisory um oversight too
if they decided to not be working there
either thank you thank you thank you
other questions seeing none I have one
oh sorry representative here sorry um
and this is you may not be able to
answer this one because you mentioned a
21% vacancy rate so that it it just let
me two thoughts uh how long does it take
to become a respiratory therapist there
is one school in New Hampshire I believe
it's River Valley um that does it I
believe it's a two-year program yeah
what does a respiratory therapist make I
mean what kind off the top of my head I
do not know but I can find out for you
all right just that was just curious y
thank
you thank you very much and I apologize
for that representative Pearson I didn't
see your
hand
okay um and i' like like to call djus
and Nick pry from um oplc please sounds
like there's a couple questions for
you good afternoon it's nice to see you
all again just for the record Diana
jurus executive director
oplc and Nicholas fry general
counsel representative go did you have a
question yes thank you I just wanted to
make sure that in the ru making you're
planning on you're going to have a plan
for students who decide that they don't
want to continue with their education in
this field and want to leave school
early so um are you kind of alluding to
the
twoyear right so there there's two
scenarios that could happen right so um
if someone is leaving licenser one of
the requirements is that they're a
student so once they're no longer a
student they can't have that license the
second component is if they are
continuing on being a student then they
could renew that
license thank
you thank you representative SL I need
to get the
pronunciation I I'm hoping you can
correct my understanding it it it sounds
as though there's a student license
involved in this uh legislation does
that sound fair uh can you explain um
this the section of the legislation
performed without a license by a student
is is there some segment of the student
population who will be exempt from lure
or am I simply
misunderstanding are you referring to um
I'm looking on four Respiratory Care
practice exemptions from lure you
talking about that section right there I
believe it's uh line
26 yes okay yeah so that's the exemption
statute so there's a carve out for um
certain students that are doing
something for their clinical practice so
that's an exemption this is to actually
allow uh The Lure is to allow students
to work at hospitals on their own that
are farther along in their
matriculations thank
you thank you and uh just to ask another
clarifying question for myself so um
this is one that do not be required for
students who just want to do their
course workor only for those who want to
make some money while practicing their
skills correct thank you
yes represent so I apologize you may
have uh said it and I didn't catch it uh
are you taking a position on the bill
are you for General infro no position
the one thing we would ask though is
that if the if the bill does go through
it would be helpful for us to have the
language temporary student license used
consistently throughout this uh proposed
bill or what would become a statute just
from our perspective because because we
have temporary licenses that we already
deal with and this would be um it would
just be less confusing for
us thank you so just for your reference
we've identified in the printed Bill
line 15 a student has OB who has
obtained a temporary license if the word
student could be entered so consistent
with lines 12 and
13 just a temporary license means
something different so temporary student
license would be specific just to this
and would just help us operationalize
that thank you that's very helpful
thank you and if there's no further
questions thank you very much is there
anybody else who wanted to speak on this
bill see sorry and if you'd like to
announce what the online was
representative Howard we had two in
support online and zero in
opposition thank you and with that this
ends the public hearing of House Bill 85
and we will reconvene again at 2:30 for
House Bill 82 thank
you
e
e e
we're not starting until 2:30 which is a
minute away but I only have two cards in
front of me so I'm not sure if all of
you are going to be here just to watch
if you're going to speak please fill out
a pink card and hand it up
okay thank you and welcome back it is
now 2:30 and I will open the hearing on
House Bill 8 2 and I will call the prime
sponsor representative Carol
Maguire uh thank you madam chair members
of the committee Carol Maguire
representing marac 27 and House Bill 82
is a request of the
oplc it is essentially a compilation of
the cleanup language that was submitted
last year on bills that didn't pass we
had a number of them that we either
voted to kill for other reasons or we
with um retained in committee and were
not passed but there this does not have
any policy differences it is
purely cleaning up the statutory
conflict between the various licensing
boards language and the oplc
language uh
it if you look at the list of
professions
involved the last three I believe are
not actually addressed except to be
added to the list of boards license
commissions Etc that are covered under
the oplc like the voluntary dual and
lactation specialist the nurse agency
registration and I think the bondsman
um I also have an amendment which I
passed out earlier which adds in some
language that I had thought I'd included
in this bill but didn't uh this is to
clarify under the Medical Imaging
Professionals that no matter how many
Specialties you are qualified for you
only need one license this is what has
been done all
along but some lawyer read the statute
and said oh you ought to have a a
separate license for each modality which
seems redundant uh this amendment uh
0010 H just says you have a license and
you've proven um your qualifications for
every every modality you're licensed for
those modalities just to simplify
things I will try to answer any
questions there are any questions from
the county representative gr thank you
Madame um yeah thank you madam chair um
representative Maguire when we were um
addressing the bill the the um these
boards last
year they were sort of set aside from
the other boards who underwent this type
of change I'm hold on could uh there's
some confusion as to whether since you
were listed as a co-sponsor whether you
can ask questions or not yes sorry I I
will mention that for example the uh
podiatrists there was no objection to
their statutory cleanup but the bill
that it was it was addressed in was a
bill to combine the board of Podiatry
with the Board of Medicine and that
policy was not accepted until the bill
was killed and this part was lost and
similarly for some of the other uh
professions I have a question the chair
um have have we changed policy I thought
that if you were a co-sponsor you had to
decide whether you would testify or ask
questions but you you simply couldn't do
both but you could do one or the other
um thank you that was my understanding
as well I don't know that might be
something that we should ask the um ask
the clerk to find out that information I
mean that's been policy in the past I
just unless unless at a chairs meeting
that's been stated differently normally
you like you say if you're offering
testimony you do don't ask questions and
uh
prefer preferably even if you are not
providing testimony you don't actively
uh ask questions but there may be cases
where information is
needed and that has been my
understanding in the past as well I was
asked the question by the clerk as to
whether that was the appropriate process
um and that's one where we can get more
information on that
okay and then I do have an actual
question then representative Pearson for
an actual question thank you madam chair
the on uh page four in the middle 19 um
you're striking out if the office denies
the issuance of a license or temporary
permit to any applicant the initial fee
deposited shall be retained as an
application
fee oplc has to
process these applications which which
is work uh why would that not why would
we not retain that if it is taking up
their time question of application fees
is covered in the um oplc statute and
rules rather than in each professional
or statute this one is only about
engineers okay I'm getting the head nod
from the from the boss back there so and
they will con confirm
that thank you and we now have
clarification that if you're a
co-sponsor you can either well for
anything you can either testify or you
can participate on the Community
Committee side and ask questions so you
cannot do
both I didn't know if there was more of
a question that you had representative
gr or if that was the whole
question I'll try again um thank you so
the under house bill 655 one of the
things that we did
is set up a statute for the oplc office
where all of these requirements that are
being repealed by the individual boards
were placed underneath that
statute so I just want to make sure and
I I believe this is right that all we're
doing is taking the boards that had not
been considered in that Administration
change to to to make these boards
compliant with all the other boards
where this previous legislation is
passed that is the intent and that's
what I try to do if I was wrong uh we'll
fix
it thank you any other
questions uh seeing none thank you very
much representative
Maguire uh next I will call up uh Kathy
bazara thurberg from the New Hampshire
Hospital
Association good afternoon for the
record again Kathy vazar thumberg
Executive Vice president the Hamshire
Hospital Association and I just wanted
to speak in support of the amendment uh
00108 from representative McGuire adding
the clarification of um The Lure process
for the medical imaging and radiation
therapy board and uh also we may be
bringing in some additional clarifying
language um if this does go to
subcommittee um just for uh consistency
within the statute so thank you thank
you are there any questions sing then
thank you very much uh next I'll call up
Joe
hos I couldn't quite realiz oh of
gilmington I was trying to see what that
was thank you very
much what was that I didn't hear that oh
I was trying to ask for a clarification
but then I read it when I looked at it
again thank thank you uh Joe H from
gilon and I came in about a minute or
two late I all I heard from the prime
sponsor was that somehow uh this is to
consolidate rather than to have separate
uh sections because my uh email that I
sent to her and the
co-sponsor uh this morning was not
answered because of the uh business here
and uh it deals
with
u
page 11
at lines 24 to 28 dealing with
auctioneers and I know that uh you know
you're changing it off from the uh board
to the office of oplc I understand that
but number
38 uh could the sponsor maybe come back
and explain to me and you uh if she has
not done already of why that you're
getting rid of
the uh 31-b colon 5 r numeral
five relative to
qualifications regarding
character is that
possible yes thank
you
problem yes that that qualification of
good professional character and with no
details was primarily Al used for
discrimination it was used to
block um unfavored social groups or on a
racial or sexual basis and it is subject
to
um bias
and irregular application it is not
something that the office can judge so
when they're doing the um
the application they can't say good
professional character check what the
requirements for the auctioneers do
require is personal references from
other
auctioneers and it is it is expected
that they will be
demonstrating the per the person's
good good professional character by
because of their recommendations and we
don't believe it should be in statute
because it cannot be uniformally
enforced thank you very much for that
clarification we do assume good
professional character on the part of
all
licenses thank you
Carol no Carol for years she's a good
State Rep from epom Epsom I think it is
it is yes representative from yeah where
I used to go years ago to Barbara and
Frank Anderson's Sherwood in with the
Trojan Horse on
there listening in on the Constitution
where I first met David uh David Welch
he told me years ago he used to go there
I didn't know him as a 20-year-old you
know but anyways uh thank you Carol
again and then because of the uh excuse
me Mr hos in this room representative
Maguire outside you can call her what
you like but here she's representative
Maguire okay yeah exactly you're right
thank you but you can call me Joe
anytime
uh yeah she said that it's it's been
used for uh discrimination purposes but
that's only one purpose of that Roman
numeral 5 because if you look back on
Roman numeral 2 it does say that other
auctioneers uh can can file uh paperwork
to uh either discredit the person or to
appraise them so it would be nice to
maybe
redefine uh that Roman numeral five to
exclude uh misuse of that for uh racial
purposes because I uh put into my
email that I was at the board of
auctioneers on a complaint
and uh I was talking about absolute
auctions and one of the members said oh
yeah that can occur at any time I said
no no no read the
definition uh I put it in here you know
has to be at the same time place cannot
be continued to a later date and even in
New York they have a statute on the
books that said the uh backup bidder
even the bidder or the backup bidder
cannot come forward at a later time to
rebid and that's something that you
could look into to perhaps put into New
Hampshire statute as an analogy as a uh
side uh well s similar
statue and uh I did listen to the
presentation this
morning not listen watch I should say
and read the captions my speakers
weren't working but anyways uh the
uh the new commissioner over there she
said that uh they don't want to have to
I mean these people work for a
livelihood and that's fine and if they
screw up then uh you know discipline
them and if they screw up too much then
oust them and then get another job and
another uh
profession and uh so I do have a real
estate case over there I can tell you
about that I won't bore you to that with
that and but uh the way I look at it
over there what it is it's a prot
protection racket because they're
protecting their people that pay
their could you just keep to the policy
and not make
accusations sir well I'm I'm talking
about character the word character isn't
here so even while uh they're being
tried to be admitted you know they're
applying for the uh license to be an
Auctioneer that once they're in that
doesn't stop there the continuation of
character should go above and beyond
because I was at uh Governor Kelly's uh
inaugurate well her first uh GNC meeting
yesterday and the pastor over there the
father he said let's have his truth and
Justice uh go further by your activities
over here I always like to say let a
truth go marching on like in the song of
the Civil War but anyways uh that being
said the last thing I want to say too is
that your character is in question too
all of you because I complained to the
house Speaker I said Article 15 of the
New Hampshire Constitution says
compensation compensation is payment for
a loss you have to use your time here
then you get paid to be paid upfront
like an attorney retainer is wrong so
you being a judge of other people's
character first your character should be
corrected an error that uh is not
corrected becomes a mistake so it would
be nice for you to look into that and do
something about it thank you uh thank
you sir and we'll take a look at this I
think a lot of those things end up in
rules as not just in the laws but we
will take a closeup all right look thank
you sir thank you next we have uh Steven
Rancourt uh representing ecba so I'd
love to know what ecba is thank
you good morning Madam chair and the
committee members my name is Steven
ranor I'm a licensed electrician in the
state of New Hampshire and I represent
the electrical contractors Business
Association I'm the executive director
and we just had some uh small concerns
we represent over 65 actual contractors
about 300 um employee so um we had a
concern on page 11 um the section starts
on line 29 the Bold wording is on line
and I can read it I just it's if you
start on line 35 says any
person failing to pass his or her first
examination by
re-examination by an examination entity
approved by the board that's all
existing obviously within one year of
the first
examination and thereafter may be
examined as often as as desired the way
that we we just feel that we not sure
the intent but the way that it reads it
seems like you can only reexamine one
more time in that onee period and that's
never been the case so we're just trying
to determine if that's trying to only
allow them to reexamine one more time or
if they can still continue to reexamine
one more time and what they're saying is
you can only reexamine one more time
without filling out a new application
we're not sure if that's what the intent
of it was was and if so it should say
that so they kind of get one re-exam
without an additional application
because I believe through their are um
rsas they have to act on the application
within 90 days so it just leaves us I
brought this to a couple of board
members and we all have some questions
to how it's written and what their
intent is not necessarily disagree but
we like some clarification to try to fix
the wording if possible thank you that's
very helpful insight um that's this is
why it's great to have public testimony
are there any questions that we have
thank you very much we will uh this will
be going to once we're done I'm sure
it'll be going to the it will be going
to the licensing subcommittee so they
will work hard on these details thank
you thank you uh next we have Mark um
condr Mary I'll have you correct me on
that because uh I got a little
intimidated and you are representing the
New Hampshire land surveyors Association
thank you it's U Mark condo
dematra thank you
yes you're familiar with it I see
no
um so I represent the New Hampshire land
surveyance Association uh we are the
first section of this bill uh that is
being um proposed uh to be affected and
I I understand um why and the reasoning
uh that the sections that are being
repealed are in here I understand um
what's happening with the consolidation
of information Ru making discipline Etc
through
oplc uh I
certainly am not necessarily um in favor
of every aspect of it uh but it just it
just seems
that we've been here now for I believe
three sessions in dealing with this
change and it seems every single time
some part of this transition has been
overlooked
and this seems to be no different um
there are multiple repeals in here where
you're repealing rulemaking uh of the
land surveyors uh statute um you're
repealing the rule making for retired
status um expiration and renewals which
I understand is all part of
administration that you know typical
day-to-day work that oplc you know
should be managing overseeing um but
then you're also repealing um
disciplinary actions and specifically
RSA 310 a70 is set to be repealed um
which lists certain violations that the
board can look at and refer to for
disciplinary action which is a standard
boilerplate information drug use bad
practice you know not being a good
Steward of the license Etc um but in
310a
586 it specifically says that the board
is required to be met by each holder of
a license to practice under the
subdivision and how disciplinary actions
by the board shall be implemented for
violations of these
standards so according to the statute
the board is still going to maintain
some Authority for disciplinary actions
yet the list of what the disciplinary
actions are is being being
repealed so we're back to square one
again which is I guess we overlooked
something and are we now going to come
back in the next session and fix this or
it it it creates uncertainty and it
creates instability on what happens now
when people are violating these statutes
when it comes to practice and what we
are seeing on an association level is a
significant increase
in people that are now practicing either
without a license um shoddy work you
know maybe they're not following all the
rules for uh for the for time reasons
Etc you know we know obviously it's very
difficult to find a lot of licensed
professions everybody's busy you know
it's the economy Etc um not as many
people coming into the workforce Etc uh
but it just seems that it would be nice
if when this
information for repeal and
consolidation is
proposed uh it would be in a more
detailed thoughtful format in such a way
as to not create confusion as to what
exactly this specifically does um
because you know again you're repealing
certain things but then there's other
things that still stand so now who has
the power of what and who's going to
decide what's what and it would just be
very helpful
if there was a a consistent standard
that people could understand follow and
know and we wouldn't be in this state of
limbo per se that um it's it's gray you
know now who is gonna maintain what and
who has certain authority over what so
um I'm certainly in understandment of
this but uh I think that there's
definitely more work that would need to
be done and we as an association are are
happy to provide our resources es
to you uh to help go through this on a
very detailed way so that when it is
done it's done correctly one time
without any unintended consequences and
that's our big concern is that we see
the unintended the unintended
consequences that occur as a result of
some of this slipshod you know language
that we're then coming back that's
housekeeping right so you know we just
want to do this um in a very consistent
and uh
you know thoughtful way so thank you
thank you we appreciate you calling us
calling attention to that and um I I
have a similar one I had 150 ft left out
of my boundary line so I it's
appreciated to always double check each
other's work so thank you very much um
were there any questions uh and thanks
next we'll call Dennis
mckenny thank you madam chairwoman my
name is Dennis mckenny I live in Ben
inton New Hampshire and Hillsboro County
I uh carry both a land surveyor license
and a uh Foresters license I have uh
some grave concerns about the direction
the office is going uh my comments today
are limited just to the first 12 lines
of the bill on page one with respect to
land
surveying
um I'm very concerned that the members
of the board themselves are being
stripped of the authority to in their
opinion uh review applications and
determine who has met the requirements
for lure I think that's a step in a a
fundamentally wrong
direction uh as Mark stated before me
I'm concerned about the disciplinary
procedure I'd like to think that uh were
there to be a complaint filed against me
that I would be judged by a jury of my
peers who have some land surveying
experience and I would ask what
qualifications knowledge experience uh
or judgment do members of the staff at
the office have to sit in judgment for
those who are licensed in any
profession the purpose of lure is to
protect the public welfare and I'm not
sure that overall with respect to land
owners here or excuse me with respect to
surveyors and particularly to land
owners that this is taking us in the
right direction uh particularly since
landowning members of the public who
engage land surveyors we are tasked with
surveying and defining or
recovering what is perhaps in the
majority of cases the most valuable
asset that they own so thank
you thank you any
questions thank you very much for your
testimony and the only remaining card I
have is from the office of prenter and
lenser and
certification so executive director
thank
you good afternoon again just for the
record de jurus executive director oplc
um just wanted to speak broadly
um the as noted this bill was a request
of the office and I just wanted to
clarify that the the intent behind the
Drafting and that working with
representative Maguire was just that to
do the cleanup statute so the policy
changes this committee has already
recommended it's been voted on you know
through the whole legislature signed by
the governor in his current law so this
actually is to avoid confusion because
there's conflicting statute but the 310
changes the umbrella for the office are
currently controlling um I'm going to
leave attorney fry to speak to um some
specific things just from our listening
to the other testimony um but just
acknowledging that um I will say
specific to the electricians exam the
intent was to the the office has that
obligation to process them and currently
the statute reads that an application
could be open for 13 years and somebody
could come back and take an exam um
operationally like the office cannot
hold those license applications open
that long and there's other statutory
implications so I'll just say when it
goes to subcommittee we're we're happy
to work it with you to to make sure that
that intent is realized the wording is
correct and that we we can
operationalize what what we'd like there
so just happy to work with you on that
and I'm sure there'll be some discussion
so we're not married to that language
just want to make sure we're able to
comply in other ways so and then just
for a few more technical pieces I'll
turn it to attorney fry oh
sorry are you are are you saying that
the disciplinary concerns that have been
expressed are already covered in
existing law that attorney fry is about
to speak to that so I'm G to turn it
over I'll let him answer that that's
that's all
right yeah so the um the statute for
land surveyors that was being referenced
RSA
310-a colon 70 um it references certain
um conduct that's considered
professional misconduct
um if you look at RSA
31012 and you compare the language of
that statute to RSA 31012 you will see
that um the language if not similar
almost nearly mirrors it so um this this
the intention of this just like
representative McGuire said was just to
clean that up so that we have one
statute and when the Public's trying to
Surf through multiple statutes they're
only having to look at one as opposed to
two um also just to speak to uh I'm just
going to Echo what representative
Maguire said again but um we do do our
best to take into um consideration the
expertise of the boards the way that's
done as you guys probably heard this
morning um is that the board sets the
criteria and objective criteria just as
representative Maguire was referencing
um so that you can have any person make
that decision and so that's how we
handle that and we've already spoke to
the electricians piece I did also want
to bring to the committee's attention
that I received a communication from New
Hampshire insurance
department so they had a proposed
amendment um to basically use generic
language to describe certain sections I
think it's sections 15 and sections 26
that deal with Insurance statutes to
reference the practice of uh practice in
New Hampshire so psychologists that
practice in New Hampshire and mental
health practitioners that practice in
New Hampshire to ensure that we're
capturing in those statutes individuals
who are licensed under RSA 310 the uh
31017 the reciprocity statute or
endorsement
statute because currently written it
just refers to the statutory schemes of
the board so they just want to make sure
that we're covering everyone for um
insurance
purposes thank you very much are there
any questions from the
committee seeing then that was very
helpful to address those questions that
we had from everybody so thank you very
much um I'm not seeing any other pink
cards so I don't see anybody else that
looks like they're here to speak on this
bill oh sorry representative Howard uh
just wanted to say online we have two in
support and two in opposition thank you
representative Howard
and with that I will close the hearing
on House Bill 82 and this is the end of
our work for the day just want to let
the committee members know the calendar
for next week has already gone out today
so you can check check that
electronically one more thing Madame
chair um for clarification 82 is going
to subcommittee uh yes I actually said
that in the midst of the discussion so
yes best to put that at the end it'll be
going to the licensing subcommittee
which representative Pearson is
chairing
e e